comments were coming in Warren himself
from cosmic wonder texting me and I saw
the title and this is information we can
most definitely use venom two official
teaser trailer release date by director
leaked photos my god I hope they reveal
a time that it's being released today
alright let's get into it
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and today we have
some absolutely amazing venom 2 news as
the director has come out and told us
exactly when the trailers gonna get here
now up to this point we've had a ton of
leaked photos and we've had plenty of
new sources telling us that we could
expect the trailer within the last two
weeks but obviously due to the corona
virus all of this could change in fact
production on most Marvel movies or TV
shows have been delayed or pushed back
and the release dates where many of the
movies have been pushed back as well
except for venom 2 now granted they are
at Sony but Morbius as well as
Ghostbusters and venom is our last hope
and the director Andy Serkis has
revealed when we are getting the trailer
we also have a leaked photo of venom and
possibly carnage as well so stay tuned
for that but the official trailer for
venom 2 is going to be coming tomorrow
Andy Serkis to Instagram today from his
official and/or picture in it is hashtag
we are the carnage tomorrow and as you
can see white both black and red so
that's venom and carnage there so this
is right from the director Andy Serkis
himself so we are officially getting the
venom 2 trailer tomorrow or the trailer
that we're going to be getting on here
we can see venom and he's hanging on the
side of a Cathedral now we know that
this Cathedral is going to be both in
the movie and the trailer we've gotten
the leaked trailer description and we've
seen behind the scenes photos as well
now what's really interesting about this
is that on the very bottom it looks like
carnage granted it does look like the
photo is cut but they all look like
they're from the same scene so if this
photo is legitimate and these photos are
all from the same scene that means we
should be seen carnage tomorrow I know a
lot of people are worried that in the
teaser trailer tomorrow we're not really
going to see carnage because in the
first venom trailer we barely assault
venom we kind of just saw black you know
what I was a leaked photos
deedy in the trailer we should be seeing
him so let me know how pumped you are
for the venom 2 trailer in the comments
down below doing nothing but trying to
find out every single day what is coming
to my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof now I've been asking around
non-stop
well we'll be a real bummer though is if
it's kind of a Dark Phoenix situation
more of an understandable Dark Phoenix
situation where they're like movie comes
out this time or I wonder if because
even though that the release date hasn't
been pushed and the pandemic has been
dying down in certain states at least in
other parts of the world some other
parts be getting worse California for
example it's been getting better I
wonder though if they'll not actually
have a release date October I think is
way too soon to be like definitely cuz
maybe they'll do what are those remember
like in the old trailer days when they
would just be like coming come soon
maybe that's what they'll do tomorrow
I'm excited to see that and if you guys
haven't seen our reaction to the
breakdown of the what the trailer
encompass is I mean that all sounded
cool to me that's kind of like when you
read a book and then you you watch the
adaptation and you're like oh cool yeah
like different is so very different
still like similarly themed and it's
always exciting to see how accurate that
trailer truly ends up being but guys if
you haven't done so already make sure to
hit the notification bell for this
channel because you best believe we're
gonna be on top of covering the trailer
oh my god could use a big trailer you
just say indefinitely far away yeah
anyway guys subscribe click the
notification bell subscribed at the
cosmic Wonder gets the lowdown on things
so fast
love the guy let's try to get some sleep
tonight